I've actually met Secret Service people
before and they're pretty intimidating
people so I'm a little scared
I took pretty well at my SATs I think
I'll do pretty well on this I consider
myself a smart person although I I did
average on a CTS in high school I enjoy
any games that like challenges me
mentally so you know crossword puzzles
riddles word puzzles things of that
nature when I was in the second grade I
took an IQ test and I actually tested in
genius levels so that's kind of not
being braggy that's just the fact of the
matter this practice test section
contains six passages each of which
describes a set of facts each passage is
followed by three test questions that
are conclusions based on the set of
facts presented in the passage you will
read the passage and then decide whether
each conclusion is true false or there
is insufficient information to decide
this section contains 18 questions and
you will have 30 minutes to complete it
mark completed more investigations than
Jake Megan completed fewer
investigations than mark Jake completed
more investigations than Rob Jake
completed more investigations than Megan
they're comparing Jake and Megan but we
don't have any we don't have any
comparison directly to Jake or Megan so
for me there's insufficient information
to decide awesome mark completed more
investigations than Rob oh dear I'm
caught in a loop that's true that is
true mark and Rob have a direct
comparison and that's through Jake so
saying that mark completed more
investigations than Rob is true true
awesome
mark completed fewer investigations than
throughout the same question but
reversed I feel like this is a trick the
statement beforehand is the direct
opposite and since we said that that was
true
mark completing fewer investigations the
opposite is true so that is false that's
false yeah
ah hell yes
Jim and Amy work in the same office Eric
and Amy both have the same position
within the Secret Service amy is a
Secret Service special agent Jim and
Eric are working on the same assignment
there are only two Secret Service
special agents at Jim and Amy's office
eric is a Secret Service special agent
amy is a Secret Service agent that means
eric is a Secret Service agent
true true because Eric and Amy have the
same position and Amy is a Secret
Service special agent huh
damn right Jim is not a Secret Service
special agent Jim could be a Secret
Service special agent actually it's
insufficient information to decide well
because there could be more people in
the office Jim and Amy and Eric all work
in the same office but there can only be
two Secret Service agents we already
established that Amy and Eric are the
agent so Jim's not true Oh what isn't
that a technicality yeah Eric and Jim
are both Secret Service special agents
and work at the same office that would
be false turn right or wait I think it
would be insufficient information to
decide because it still doesn't
establish because we don't know if Jim's
a Secret Service special agent yeah and
we don't know if Eric works at Jimmy
name is office insufficient information
to decide more I thought about it the
more confused I got it was just like
then I was thinking about the question
and all the lines and then it's just
like I had to step back and then I would
get the answer I'd like to think that I
have a logical brain I know that I'm a
visual person and so seeing things
written out is not the ideal form for me
to do problem solving no offense to the
quiz maker but I felt like they were
easy is just that the distant tax of
every statement could lend itself to
caused by confusion I am always bad with
decision-making I constantly weigh pros
and cons I go back and forth so actually
I should have known I would have done
bad on the
test so I guess I don't know myself well
either they're able to make these these
decisions at a pretty quick pace and you
know oftentimes probably their life is
on the line and so for someone to have
these kind of problems going on in their
head while they're also in in a in a
stressful situation is is pretty
impressive yeah we're about to give us
like the official like certificate or
metal and they're like but wait and now
you step in front of a bullet and and we
run away prying